Carl, what did you bring for show-and-tell?
One second.
Dad!
I brought the Nissan Pathfinder my family took on vacation.
This mud is from the Okefenokee Swamp, deep inside Georgia.
We even towed a local out of the swamp.
He was cool.
These hoof prints are from some mountain goats we met in White Fish, Montana.
I beat their leader in a staring contest.
We then went off the beaten path,...
...complete isolation,...
...living off the land.
This red clay is from an ancient Indian mud ritual.
It granted me access into the fourth world.
No way.
Yes way.
Where's that from?
The mall.
The all-new Nissan Pathfinder.
It's our most innovative Pathfinder ever.
Nissan: Innovation that Excites.